When I was six,
my father told me that I was made
out of tiny cells filled with chromosomes
that would control my fate.
I thought, "That's amazing.
There are so many mysterious things
in there, and I want to know more.”
I read about Galileo and Darwin,
and I became a scientist.
At that time, hardly anything was known.
We did not yet know that the chemical
elements came from exploded stars,
that everything you see around you
was recycled from inside of stars.
So we did not know we are recycled stars.
But we set off to measure the Big Bang,
and we measured the map of the cosmic
microwave background radiation,
using millimeter waves
and it's the entire sky
wrapped around on to an oval
so you can see it.
We see that there are hot and cold
spots in this Big Bang material.
Now we say, well, that’s because those
were there in very, very beginning,
who knows exactly why,
but they led to the existence of galaxies,
stars, planets and, eventually, people.
No spots, no people.
So it turned out to be important.
So then how did that work?
What happened next?
Well, we said let's take pictures.
So, of course, we take pictures of the
sky with the Hubble Space Telescope.
This picture was taken around 1995,
and it shows galaxies far, far, far away.
It shows what you can get
with the telescope
that's about eight feet in diameter
and can observe visible light.
So we were thrilled to have this picture.
And it shows thousands of galaxies.
They were unable to include
the most distant galaxies,
the ones that would be
as they were being born,
so there are no baby pictures
of galaxies in this picture.
We needed to have an even bigger
and more powerful telescope
that could pick up the infrared light
from the most distant universe
that has been stretched out
by the expansion of the universe.
So we didn't know what we would find.
So astronomers wrote a book and they said,
"Please build us an even more
powerful telescope."
And we did.
This is the James Webb Space Telescope,
you see a gigantic mirror,
it's hexagonal, it's coated with gold
so it reflects infrared light.
It is 21 feet across.
It is protected by a five-layer
metalized plastic sunshade
as large as a tennis court.
This telescope is so large
that it could not fit into the rocket
without being folded up like origami.
It's an incredible engineering
accomplishment
to be able to even conceive
and build this telescope.
So we built it.
And then we've launched it.
It went up into space from French Guiana
on Christmas morning, 2021.
It was a perfect launch.
The Arianespace company sent it
straight to where we needed to go.
So we think we can have 20 years
of operational scientific observations
with this great new telescope.
And it took only two minutes
to go through the tropical clouds up
towards the vacuum of outer space.
Now I want to show you
how it unfolded in outer space,
this origami telescope.
First we unfolded the solar panels.
Then we unfold the transmitter antenna
so we can talk back and forth.
Then we unfold the panels
that hold the great sunshade in place.
This takes us actually
two weeks in real life.
You see it compressed here
so we can show it to you.
This is just a miracle of modern
engineering, and it’s so complicated.
And you'd say, is there any way
you could have done this
without this great telescope?
And the answer seems to be no.
You need a big telescope.
It needs to be in outer space.
It needs to be cold, so it doesn’t glow
and emit its own infrared.
And third is, being very carefully
unrolled all by commands from here.
So you ask, how could you possibly
make such a complicated thing work?
Well, number one, practice,
practice, practice,
rehearse and test,
fix it when it's not quite right.
And then, of course, have two
of everything, if you possibly can.
And third, have arguments
with all of your friends to say,
is this really right?
Can you think of anything that's a mistake
that we might be making
that we should fix before we launch it?
So the last step is finally
to unfold the telescope itself.
And there it is in outer space,
not quite ready to use because it's still
warm and has not yet been focused.
So we had to wait for several weeks
for it to start to cool down
to a low enough temperature
that we could do the next steps.
We send it to a place
called Lagrange Point 2,
about a million miles farther out
from the Sun than we are.
This is a place that moves around
the Sun with us every year,
so the telescope does not
get any farther away.
It is the only place that we can put
a telescope where this is the setup,
and you can have the one-sided umbrella
that protects the telescope
from the Sun and the Earth and the Moon.
So the next thing is, what did we see?
We focused the telescope
and took some pictures
of the same star
we looked at with the Webb.
So the fuzzy picture is the Spitzer
Space Telescope launched in 2003.
The sharp picture
is the new Webb telescope.
We were so thrilled that it worked.
We got a nice, sharp image of the star,
and we can calculate now
the sensitivity of this object,
that if you were a bumblebee,
a square centimeter object
hovering at the distance
of the Moon from the Earth,
away from the telescope,
we would be able to see you,
both the sunlight you reflect
and the heat you emit.
So there are no bumblebees in space,
but there's something out there
that we don't know.
And I'm so sure that we're going to get
a great surprise from this telescope.
So I'll show you what we look at.
Here is an example of a place
where stars are being born as we speak.
Now we know, more or less,
that stars explode and produce dust,
which goes and is recycled into new stars.
This is a place where
the recycling is happening.
Stars are being born in this beautiful
cloud of glowing gas and dust.
On the left-hand side shows you
what we see with visible light
with the Hubble Space Telescope.
The right-hand side shows you
that you can begin to see through the dust
with an infrared camera that we also have
on the Hubble telescope.
It's beautiful.
Astronomers want to see inside and we will
with the Webb telescope.
We can look at everything
in the solar system from Mars on out.
So this is a pretty interesting one,
everybody knows Mars might be alive.
What about Europa?
Europa is a satellite of Jupiter.
It has a liquid ocean covered with ice.
We know because we sent a probe
out there named after Galileo himself,
and we saw this and took this picture.
Now we know that there is water
coming out from the cracks
between the ice blocks
and once in a while,
they can be watched from here.
And we are planning to send a probe
to fly through the water jets
and see if there might be
any organic molecules in them.
Is it alive? Well, maybe.
We'll be watching this satellite
with the Webb telescope as well.
Farther on out in the solar system,
we've been watching Titan.
Titan is the only moon in the solar system
that has oceans and lakes
and rain and rivers
and an atmosphere on the surface.
It is so cold, though,
that its liquid hydrocarbons,
methane and ethane,
that you would use for fuel here on Earth.
So we'll be examining this
with the Webb telescope
and we'll be sending a probe out there
to land with even a helicopter
to go exploring.
So is this a place
that's interesting for life?
Possibly.
People ask me all the time,
are we sure that the kind
we have here is the only kind?
Well, maybe not.
And if not, this is a good place
to look because it's different,
but it still has solids,
liquids and gases,
and it has a liquid hydrocarbon,
which might be a possible solvent.
We'll see.
Next thing we want to look at is,
are there planets around other stars
that might have life?
So we will be looking in this way
at small stars that have
Earth-sized planets.
When a planet goes in front of the star,
it can block some starlight,
some of the starlight goes through
the atmosphere of the planet,
if it has one,
and on its way to our telescope,
and we can analyze that
and look for the chemistry
of such an atmosphere.
So, number one, does a little
Earth-like planet out there
have an atmosphere?
Number two, does it have any
molecules in the atmosphere?
And number three, could they be water?
Is there enough water out there
so that there could be a liquid ocean?
Well, maybe.
We will find out and we'll tell you.
So are we alone?
Well, I don't know.
But we'll be going on after this project
to even more powerful telescopes
that can examine little Earths
around stars like the Sun.
And then we'll be able to say,
"Really, really, are they like home?"
And maybe yes.
We will be telling you
all about what we find out,
beginning with our first scientific
observations this summer.
So please stay tuned.
Astronomers travel with the speed of light
and the speed of imagination.
(Applause)